about ten years ago when I was in
college in Ballyfermot and abend we'd
seen Hercules and we'd seen Mulan and we
were inspired by how interesting
it was to take you know indigenous art
or national art and and mix it with
other influences and find a way to do
something with 2d animation that could
only be done in 2d animation and then we
found this bootleg copy of VHS that I've
been passed around the College of that
thief and the cobbler and I really blew
my socks off as a student animator it's
just amazed at the design and and I
thought that was really impressive
because he was doing something again I
thought that was Dick Williams was doing
something I thought was really special
in 2d animation you taken Persian art
and doing something that was you know so
as an animator I was inspired by the
idea that maybe we could do something
with Irish art would get this Gaelic
tradition that we had and we had looked
at the history and the legends around
the book house and there was a movie in
there somewhere
it took us six years to find it but we
found a movie eventually and the money
eventually no we just did joke about the
kids but mom I want to see the movie
with the medieval monks and her making a
manuscript please and you know and III
think you know naively a23 when I
started out I didn't I didn't think like
that and we learned a lot in the process
of putting the project together we
hooked up with two great co-producers
Vivian found flattering in Didier brunet
maybe film in the Samba tour in 2003
they had some success with their feature
the Triplets of Belleville and that was
a really beautiful story and the
tradition of animation and comic books
in France and Belgium was something you
know and inspiring to tap into
especially with their talented teams and
so that was sort of the thing that with
this weird movie about medieval monks
kind of found a home with these kind of
crazy producers who were willing to take
a punt on it so we kind of were able to
put the finance together and yeah make a
movie that you wouldn't imagine will get
made
you